SPEAKER: Willie Mays changed
the way the game was played.
He is the most spectacular
baseball player
that ever played.
None of them could do
what Willie Mays could do.
You had to experience it
to understand what he meant.
He was baseball.
♪ Say hey! ♪
♪ Willie ♪
SPEAKER 2: He dominated
the entirety of the game.
SPEAKER 3:
He put out
over 7,000 baseball players
playing center field.
SPEAKER 4: Willie was the leader
of our team.
I wanted nine guys on that field
to play together.
Once we play together,
we can win.
Willie took all
the Black athletes
and held them on his shoulders.
SPEAKER 5: Here's Willie Mays,
the first great
African American superstar
to show the world that baseball
is changing.
SPEAKER 6: San Francisco
accepted him as an athletic star
but not as a person they wanted
to live next door to.
He could not buy there.
SPEAKER 3:
He stated, "I'm going to make
changes by going out
and being the greatest
baseball player that I can be."
SPEAKER 5:
The epitome of Willie Mays
was the famous catch
in the World Series.
Thirty yards went to 40 yards,
and a little further.
ANNOUNCER:
And he makes a miraculous catch
as he stops a step short
of the wall.
SPEAKER 3: That catch is one
of the greatest
athletic performances
in sports history.
WILLIE MAYS: It's difficult
right now to even try
to explain to you how much
I love baseball.
I think we had what you call
a love affair.
SPEAKER 7:
There goes Willie Mays...
the greatest player
to ever play this game.
INTERVIWER:
Are you, Willie Mays,
the greatest baseball player
of all time?